hundreds of supporters of President
Jerry Wilson are once again boarding to
the capital Brazilian Sunday
honking their car horns to call for an
end of all isolation measures in the
country people think isolation is not
being done in the right way there is no
previous experience in the world of
closing everything down just to see what
happens
robell scenario rallies have become a
weekly event in this city coronavirus
cases are still increasing rapidly
across the country but the president is
keeping up his fight against distancing
measures imposed by local authorities
also notto greeted his supporters in
front of the presidential palace what
was new is that for the first time he
and his entourage were wearing face
masks but that didn't stop him from
shaking hands and embracing a young
supporter dressed in a military uniform
and attacking what he calls the tyranny
of total isolation measures calling for
the reopening of the economy and urging
people to get back to work we will
change Brazil's destiny even with this
crisis affecting the entire world thanks
to ministers thanks to the wonderful
people here we are together
Brazil is ours more than 15,000
Brazilians have died of copy 19 so far
though experts fear the figure is
probably much higher with many cases
missed because of insufficient testing
and nowhere is the situation worse than
in the Amazon region and Sunday
residents of this neighborhood in Manaus
took her into their own hands to
disinfect the streets of the city with
the highest rate of infections per
capita in the country we took that
initiative because we lost we have a lot
of victims in our neighborhood and that
was the tendency if we did not act and
now there are growing worries of the
virus fast spreading upriver into
isolated indigenous reserves at least 11
tribe members have already been
confirmed dead but without testing nor
access to adequate medical care nobody
knows how many lives will be lost
Alessandra fe80 al Jazeera